voilà il est donc bientôt au 20h et dans
quelques secondes les voeux de jacques
chirac le président de la république
française
mes chers compatriotes je suis heureux
de vous retrouver ce soir est de vous
dire les voeux très chaleureux que je
forme pour vous pour les vôtres et pour
notre pays à l'occasion exceptionnelle
de cette dernière année avant un nouveau
millénaire
l'année 1998 s'achève elle nous laissera
des souvenirs forts la joie sans
frontières de la coupe du monde symbole
de fraternité et d'union entre les
peuples
le cinquantenaire de la déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme
célébrée avec coeur et enthousiasme
comme une promesse pour l'avenir
en même temps hélas de nombreuses
victimes tombées de au kosovo en afrique
centrale en irak tandis que des
catastrophes dévastés en quelques heures
des régions entières comme nous l'avons
vécue récemment aux côtés de l'amérique
centrale
chez nous le chômage la misère qu'elles
soient matérielles ou morales n'ont pas
diminué comme nous l'aurions souhaité et
puis nous avons vu la mondialisation en
marche un monde c'est vrai où les crises
notamment financières se propage très
rapidement mais aussi et surtout un
monde de plus en plus ouvert où tout
circule les hommes et richesses
l'information la connaissance un monde
plein d'énergie plein de vitalité
riche de fraternité
inventé ces changements nous inquiète
parfois
et pourtant ils seront porteurs de
progrès si nous savons non seulement les
maîtriser mais surtout si nous savons
aux humanités civilisé cette
mondialisation ce combat pour un monde
plus humain ou doivent prévaloir le
droit et la fraternité est celui de la
france c'est le mien nous sommes tout à
fait capables de réussir parce que nous
le ferons en sang c'est ensemble que
nous allons changer d'époque préparer
l'avenir c'est le premier devoir de tout
responsable c'est vous donner la parole
c'est être à l'écouté de vos aspirations
et de vos préoccupations
c'est proposer clairement un chemin pour
vous permettre de donner le meilleur de
vous-même d'épanouir vos talents de
réaliser vos projets aux responsables
publics
vous demandez d'abord du courage le
courage de dire le courage de faire le
courage de changer et d'assumer
nous avons tout à gagner à poser
franchement les problèmes tout le monde
sait ce qui marche bien et ce qui marche
moins bien dans notre pays en dépit d'
immenses progrès trop de pesanteur trop
d'habitude nous tire encore en arrière
trop souvent des intérêts particuliers
l'emportent et nous ne jouons pas assez
collectif
choisissons résolument d'avancé 7 ainsi
que nous ouvrirons notre vie politique
que nous ferons mieux vivre notre
démocratie
c'est ainsi que nous inventerons une
nouvelle solidarité une solidarité
responsable pour ramener vers l'emploi
ceux qui en sont exclus parfois depuis
longtemps
c'est ainsi que nous donnerons à nos
enfants une bonne formation pour leur
emploi c'est ainsi que nous garantirons
l'avenir de nos retraites
c'est ainsi que nous pourrons jouer
toutes nos cartes dans un espace
européen vers l'europe l'europe est déjà
une longue histoire
elle est encore un long chemin de plus
en plus elle sera notre quotidien la
création de l'euro ouvre une ère
nouvelle
le ronde va changer l'europe est d'abord
les mentalités et je tiens ce soir à
vous rendre hommage l'euro s'est d'abord
le fruit de vos efforts et de vos succès
c'est aussi l'expression de votre
lucidité et de votre esprit d'ouverture
car si vous ne l'aviez pas voulu si vous
ne l'aviez pas rendue possible
nous serions restés en dehors de cette
grande aventure pour nous français c'est
une chance
l'euro nous apportera plus de choix dans
nos achats
les prix plus bas de nouvelles parts de
marché de nouvelles possibilités
d'investissements et donc d'emplois il
nous offre
il nous apportera plus de stabilité dans
un monde incertain plus de force
face aux grands pôles économiques et
politiques qui existent ou se
développent sur la planète
mais pour que nous puissions être parmi
les meilleurs il faut défaire les noeuds
qui nous empêchent d'avancer parfois
libérer nos capacités d'innovation
baisser nos impôts et nos charges qui
sont parmi les plus élevés d'europe
valoriser ce qui crée tirer le meilleur
parti des nouvelles technologies voilà
comment nous devons construire notre
avenir c'est une belle ambition c'est
une ambition raisonnable et c'est la
mienne
des responsables publics mes chers
compatriotes vous attendez aussi qu'il
fasse respecter la loi
vous souhaitez de l'autorité une
autorité intelligente et responsable
sûr de sa raison d'être qui est tout
simplement le respect de nos valeurs
républicaines
ces valeurs et notamment l'intégration
et l'égalité des chances sont parfois
menacer la sécurité des biens et des
personnes n'est pas garantie par tous
l'éducation la prévention sont
indispensables mais vous savez aussi que
la sanction de l'edpams je rappelle que
la sécurité est la première des libertés
enfin je sais que vous aspirez à plus
d'unité autant vous appréciez les vrais
débats autant vous êtes lassés des
vaines querelles
je pense comme vous qu'il faut'' éviter
ce qui divise inutilement ce qui blesse
les gens dans leurs convictions
il ya aujourd'hui bien d'autres
priorités bien d'autres enjeux partout
je constate une formidable envie d'agir
et de créer une chouette de comprendre
le besoin de réussir je vois à l'oeuvre
de nouvelles énergies qui transforme peu
à peu notre pays si nous savons les
encourager les libérer alors oui la
france sera bien parti pour le siècle
qui vient
partout je rencontre des femmes et des
hommes qui se rassemblent pour faire
progresser les choses sur beaucoup de
sujets c'est possible nous avons bien vu
ce que peut la france quand elle est
unie enthousiaste tourné vers la même
ambition une ambition partagée
voilà mes chers compatriotes de
métropole et d'outre-mer de l'étranger
level que je forme pour la france
sachons être lucide inventif généreux
sachons créé renouer tous les dialogues
ga sachons nous rassembler pour le bien
de la nation
je souhaite à chacune et à chacun
d'entre vous à ceux qui ont la chance
d'être en famille entourée de
l'affection et de la solidarité des
leurs comme à ceux qui sont seuls
ce soir je souhaite une bonne et une
heureuse année
vive la république et vive la france
voilà c'était donc les voeux de jacques
chirac pour 1999